This is my chance to prove myself!
'sup guys!
wait a minute!
you guys aren't the real avengers. I can tell. Hulk gives it away.
awww, that was awesome!
Did Liz get a new top?
no, you've seen that one before
but never with that skirt
we should probably stop starting before it gets creepy though
too late
you guys are losers
so, to become an avenger. Are there like trials, or an interview?
just don't do anything I would do.
and definitely don't do anything I wouldn't do.
there's a little grey area in there and that's where you operate.
That's not a hug, I'm just grabbing the door for you
good luck out there
listen, I know school sucks.
Peter! are you still with us?
uuuh, yeah!
I know you want to save the world.
but, you're not ready yet.
you're the spider-man
no I'm not. I'm not, this is just a costume. This is just
you were on the ceiling!
stay close to the ground
and stay out of trouble
forget the flying monster guy, there are people who handle this sort of thing
i'm sick of him treating me like a kid all the time!
but you are a kid
this is my chance to prove myself
peter, what is going on with you!
I'm really sorry, I'm so busy, I'm slammed
don't mess with me
cause I will kill you, and everybody you love
Hey true believers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be so awesome.
So Spiderman trailer let's break it down there
is a new round of the Spider-Man giveaway
that's going on right now to all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video be sure to click that
bell to enable alerts so you don't miss out
on anything.
I just love the avengers run and you guys
totally are not the avengers this movie is
all about him still becoming Spider-Man like
Iron Man gives in that speech look kit you're
not ready for the big stuff yet leave the
flying man in the suit to people like the
avengers their people that handle that.
So he's trying to become an A-list avenger.
Even though we kind of already joined the
team, and Captain America Civil War that was
kind of like his tryout you get a taste for
his life in school like an just sitting there
obviously you season day over there.
Her name is Michelle in the movie you can
see she looks kind of dumpy so I wonder if
there's going to be some arc in the film or
in the trilogy where she ends up becoming
like supermodel hot is because in real life
this is what she looks like most of the time.
So the way she talks about herself and the
movie she's probably Michelle Gonzales was
like a really bad ass detective that Spider-Man
works with.
She was his girlfriend for appeared in the
comics.
When he was not with Mary Jane.
So even though the doing really classic Spider-Man
stuff the trying to do it in a way that they
haven't done before.
That's why we have Michael Keaton's vulture,
who is supposed to have this horrific entrance
like the way they cut them into the trailer.
He seems kind of scary but Tom Holland spoke
about him he was going to terrify Peter the
first time, he appears.
So you see a little bit about his creation
and that should Towery tech left over from
the avengers invasion.
So you see, this is already become in avengers
world is to the whole reason for going with
a look like this as opposed to say a comic
book look with the feathers, just because
a lot of the aesthetic of the Marvel movies
flows from Iron Man's technology so it just makes
sense that he would have technology based
villains like this.
So classic.
Spider-Man villains with a slight Tony Stark
Marvel twist we see a longer scene of him
jumping off the Washington Monument testing
out his glider tech Kevin Feige teesed there'd
be all kinds of bells and whistles we haven't
seen it with the suit, but that just like
the spider-light, things that you saw from the
comics all the stuff that Tony Stark built
into the suit is gonna be classic Spider-Man
stuff the whole idea here is that they're
restoring Spider-Man to his true self like
that's the whole idea and bringing him back to
Marvel bringing him home so all the stuff
that they added to the suit like everybody
is wondering what else it does is all stuff
that goes way back in the comics so we've
already seen a couple things they can do like
we've seen the Stark tech web shooters we've seen
the digital readout on the spider-light which
is also right out of the comics and I wouldn't
be surprised if he has some advanced communication
devices in there too like you see him flying
with Iron Man at the end of the trailer there's
probably some tech built-in there to help
his suit, communicate with Iron Man's suit but
it isn't like a full Iron Man suit I wouldn't
be surprised though if it's resistant to like
knife wounds, but it probably couldn't stop a
really big bullet or like a giant energy blast
like the vulture has here.
So even though it's a Stark tech suit it's
not as strong as a Tony Stark, Iron Man suit
or even like Black Panthers Vibramium Weave.
costume although that would be really
bad ass a Spider-Man vibranium weave costume.
Maybe for the second infinity war film you
see him hanging out with ned leeds here this
is one of his best friends in high school.
He eventually becomes hobgoblin in the comics.
I don't know what kind of plans they have
for that in the marvel universe that might
never come to pass, but you can see the homecoming
banner here, it's
Spider-Man homecoming because there's a homecoming
dance in high school and he's also coming home
to Marvel so one of my other favorite parts
of the comic con footage was in here too, him
getting in trouble for watching footage of
himself on YouTube like he's watching a clip
from that airport battle scene of him swinging
around Antman the other big thing that's different
from really big Spiderman movies too is Ned
Leeds then in the trailer finds out his identity
that typically didn't happen in Spider-Man
films till much much later in the trilogies
usually if it was Harry he kept the big secret
from him and it became this big rift between
them but now one of his best friends knows
his secret.
Maybe Michelle will learn his secret through
the course of the film too. The Iron Man speech
is just so great too don't do anything I would
do don't do anything I wouldn't do that gray
area in between.
That's where you operate then gives him that
awkward,
Tony Stark,
"I'm not your dad,
I'm afraid of intimacy" hug as he pushes him
out the door it like a hug and pushing him
out the door the exact same time classic Tony
Stark move, he's given it to thousands of women
in the past but you can kind of see how he
doesn't want to acknowledge that he thinks
of Peter as like a son or he's not a father
figure he's one of those people.
That's almost afraid to tap into certain emotions
that he feels like he might have like he has
that psychoanalysis sit down with The Hulk at the end of Iron Man 3 "Let's not open
that can of worms" Maybe Doctor strange can
help them with that, because he's an actual
trained physician but don't you just wonder
looking at this Michael Keaton footage what
it is that they said to him, that convinced
him to sign back on for the movie because
he was rumored for the role a long time ago
last year and then reportedly he turned it
down, but then later came back on.
So I wonder if they changed the script or they
changed something about the character or they
showed him something that he really enjoyed
but I just love the idea of a vicious evil
Michael Keaton he's one of those actors that
has this intensity that you don't see a lot
and it gets so meta-when you think about him as
Batman like that's one of the reasons why
his Batman was so great, just because he was
so intense, but the thing about Peter here
is the way they cut this trailer makes it
look like the vulture has just handed him
his ass like he's almost crying here he's in
the hoodie still so this seems like it's before
he has the Stark tech suit.
So like the teaser yesterday that looks like
it took place before Captain America Civil
War where he gets that Stark tech suit.
Maybe this film will jump back and forth in
time just a little bit because they said they're
not doing the uncle Ben origin story, but
they'll at least acknowledge it somehow, most
of this film is going to be localized to Queens
with the exception of that Washington Monument
shot in the scenes where you see him walking
around the avengers building with Tony Stark.
So at some point he will go see a bunch of
cool stuff happening at the avengers base
this big action set piece here does this not
remind you of that Spider-Man 2 Toby McGuire
train scene except he's holding a giant ferry
together from getting ripped apart.
So just like that much crazier that gives
you an idea of how strong his webbing is but
it sounds like just based on the tone of this
trailer that your Tony Stark is only going
to be in a little bit of the movie but will
help him out with whatever the big final battle's
gonna be because you see a couple different
types of fights in here you see him facing
off against the fake avengers robbers using
chitauri tech to rob that ATM, he takes them
down pretty quickly, but things start to escalate
as you see the vulture come in, just crashed
through the ceiling here.
So very quickly things spiral out of control
and that's where uncle Tony comes in but let
me know what you think about Spider-Man in
high school like a lot of this is just very
a day in the life of Spider-Man like he has
to go to school just like everybody else.
So every time something crazy happens and
he wants to go help.
Yes to find an excuse to leave.
So there is some comic con footage that they
did not include in this, but it's just of Michelle
chasing them out in the hallway just going
where you going Peter Parker like every time
he runs away but it'll be really fun to see
how they try to distinguish the cinematography
of Spider-Man in this new Marvel film, because
if you go back and you watch the Toby McGuire
the Andrew Garfield films they slowly tried
to be more and more advanced with the way
they shot him when you look at this amazing
Spider-Man Andrew Garfield trailer it's all
first person perspective for a large portion
of it like you don't even see the spider suit
and it.
But the big difference with Tom Holland is
that like even that teaser that they just
dropped it's all first person but it's like
he's filming himself so it's like Spider-Man
for a YouTube generation like YouTube exists
in this world.
So of course.
Spider-Man would film himself doing stunts
that's even a big part of how he earn money
working at the daily bugle following Spider-Man
around quote unquote, I know Spider-Man really
well.
He lets me take pictures of him, so if Peter
Parker were gonna be following.
Spider-Man around it be all video so.
Just imagine a whole bunch of selfies of Spider-Man
just doing crazy trick shots taking villains
down, but as you can see, it's the exact same
suit from Civil War.
You know, maybe a few minor upgrades during
the film, it's all CG even though he does
wear a cloth suit on set like this is what
it looks like when is walking around while
there filming and if you guys didn't know
they do the exact same thing for Robert Downey
Junior he has not worn an actual Iron Man
suit on set in a long time it's all CG 100%.
So just imagine when they're shooting this
Captain America: Civil War scene, Robert Downey
Junior is just walking around like this in
his street clothes, but a lot of you are asking
how is this going to connect to the other
avengers films so largely I think they want
Spider-Man to feel like his own self-contained
universe with other avengers stuff happening
in the background.
That's where you have Tony Stark the avengers
building.
Chitauri tech left over from the avengers
invasion, but a lot of his core characters
will be people from Queens that he goes to
school with.
So even when he's swinging around the city
trying to help people it's still gonna feel
relatively self-contained like you got to
be jetting across the world every single day
with the probably do is at least one of the
post credits scenes will be a related avengers
film like it will be an Iron Man moment or
it will be something for one of the other
big films let me know in the comments which
post credits scenes do you want to see them
attached to Spider-Man they could do with
Thor, but that's kind of unrelated, it's out
in outer space he's never met thor before
they could do a direct avengers tie-in that's
actually more likely but if anything I think
will just be teasing the next Spider-Man film
just because it will be trilogy Tom Holland
signed on for three films knows how many will
do after that.
But that does not include his Marvel contract
to do the avengers crossover.
So, if
Spider-Man comes in one of the other Marvel
films that's a completely separate deal from
a business standpoint, if anything I'm hoping
that we see a little bit from his friend from
Brooklyn.
Although we don't really know where Captain
America is as of right now he's kind of on
the run last time seen in Wakanda with Bucky
and Black Panther. So it looks great
so far, but this is just that teaser trailer
will probably get a whole bunch more story.
The next time they drop the trailer which
will probably be around the Super Bowl.
But there is a second trailer they're dropping
tonight, like an international version of
the trailer that has a little bit a different
footage so all totally do a video for that
too, but that wont post till later in the morning,
but I just I love the idea that they're just dropping
this all right now they could totally waited
till next year but Kevin Feige was just like
nah, we're just all dump it right now here
you go, everybody have fun.
So first Spider-Man giveaway winner.
Congratulations to spider fan you and a comics
all and she giftcard please private message
me on the back-end of my channel so I can get
your contact details! I'll name another winner
when I post that new trailer video in a couple
hours.
So get hyped good time to be a true believer
right now while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my ranking of
all the Spider-Man movies
so far you can click here to learn all about
savitar on the flash thank you so much for watching
everybody, let's high five I'll see you guys tonight!